so there is a high turnover rate at the
white house I don't have to tell you the
turnover rates ridiculous you could be
forgiven for not knowing a lot of like
if you said to me no who's the Secretary
of Defense I can't remember their song
you know who's the national security
advisor who was it yesterday I don't
know but well okay but one guy who's
always there is Stephen Miller 33 year
old Stephen Miller from Santa Monica
right here yeah he's a great-looking guy
and he has been profiled this week he's
now he's the immigration hardliner to
the major paper is the post in the New
York Times both profiled him on the
front page this week so we thought it
was time to do 25 things you don't know
about Stephen
we originally I used to be of credit to
US magazine but screw them they never
thanked me for it so I'm just saying
we're stealing it now it's ours I'm
never gonna mention you again 25 things
Bill Maher's 25 things you don't know
about Stephen Miller I'm currently
dating a headless Nordstrom mannequin in
high school I was voted most likely to
call my mummified mother's hair
I think tacos are stealing jobs from
hamburgers oh I would kill to have hair
like Donald Trump correction I have
killed to have hair like that
I'm a cancer I don't know my
astrological sign
if I need time alone I go anywhere the
worst part about my car is smelling like
wet dogs is that I don't own dog I use
spray-on hair but not on my head
[Applause]
and college my style was dubbed Nazi
geek which explains my nickname peewee
German and I can't get automatic sync's
to turn on because I don't have a soul
you